the toughest part of living in Los
Angeles hmm the toughest part of living
in Los Angeles I think that the one of
the hardest parts of living in Los
Angeles is the well I think it's that
things are very far apart okay and
people are very far apart here
things are spread out and people are
very you know homebound I think the lack
of community for me the lack of family
and the lack of that kind of those kinds
of bonds were where you have in the
original places that you we come from la
is a city of people coming from other
places so their roots are elsewhere so
there's not a lot of roots here the here
it's an amalgamation of people so people
are here to work and do things so
there's not a lot of community if you
will actually it can be a little lonely
it can be lonely I would say
you